der schnellste Jahresrückblick der Welt
teil 2 CDU Chef merärz sagt er könnne
sich eine Zusammenarbeit mit der AFD auf
kommunaler Ebene vorstellen will das
danach aber nicht so gemeint haben wenn
zurückrudern irgendwann olympisch wird
mit Friedrich März holen wir Gold
SachsenAnhalt verbietet das gender mit
Sonderzeichen an Schulen damit ist
Gendern in keinem Bundesland Pflicht
aber in einem Bundesland verboten 1:0
für die sprachpolizistinnen oh
sorry habbecks heizungsgesetetzt setzt
Deutschland beim Heizen das Ziel bis
2045 klimaneutral zu werden also
spätestens dann wenn eh alles zu spät
die Hamas greift Israel an der Gazakrieg
beginnt dazu gibt's wirklich nichts
lustiges zu sagen nach einem Urteil des
Verfassungsgerichts Fehlen der
Bundesregierung 60 Milliarden Euro der
Grund buchungstricks damit ist die
Bundesregierung endgültig auf dem
seriositätslevel von Carsten maschmeer
und Chico angekommen nur dass beide mehr
Geld haben die Linksfraktion löst sich
auf weil Sarah Wagenknecht eine neue
bisschen links bisschen Rechtspartei
gründen will wählbar für alle die gerne
Döner essen es aber doch lieber hätten
wenn die Bude ein deutscher
Familienbetrieb wäre